Prim
switching switching
switching switching inglese puge
italiano desg neurologica desg
neologica é melhor falar com paciente
vai testar se elorgan neurol né
Sì
neologica
simul cendo che quando
cammin
FR
muscol da
perando
[Musica]
passo
possib
Forgione
neurologica congan
neurologica rapida cheerio che C
mostre cammino
di visto
[Musica]
problema un
po
non perché è important perché
eser disorganizzazione
neurologica un tempo tempo che SP
consulta se io consulta con
disorganizzata
buc testi
alteria
cond la risposta
Daia ma an qualche tes senò rispond
al
all problema
fantastico non
eserci
consulta un
tempo che
Dea non m esercizio in casa un tempo
minimo
minch
perché tempo
che o lembra o
Consi sovrascrive sovrascrive sof
cammino
vin scrittura software no perché un
nuovo software
smello stovello
sta Come si chiama con virus con virus
computatore scriere un nuovo software do
cammino important C
Visto Secondo tes non è un test una
manovra la manovra Ponci aon cavesso
pazien desid maga e volta Maga Ces penci
e
Deta
levanta Gro perfetto poco tempo
perfet
pron sta alta un poco alta forse perché
allora
Gro Cè non
f
olab m
l nens pero
tes Sì desf tessi f
e
sei resultado é da exens Ou se doest que
Eu que fazendo Esse aqui é um teste a se
Ele deixar Assim se deixa a cabea Assim
fazendo Esse teste desse a Mistura do m
deixar neutro deixando Outro Tem que
ficar de olho também NAS mos da paciente
para Ela est fazendo nenhum movimento
que seja Outro teste [ __ ] um teste
cruzado Endi Tem que estar sempre a mzin
aberta Porque por exemplo se a paciente
tiver Assim pode est
fazendo
testos dup
D Sì
perché
formazion un muscolo un muscolo ma
muscolo esio
non poss
usra
sempre
to un po
po bucc ap solo un poco
ioci pa
pa
da
Noc
barae o nome do mculo testando tando da
falata D G muscolo che sta falata Eh è
un muscolo da chinesiologia f o meglio
perché la sua la caratteristica
anatomica delele
è mus
informa del qualche muscolo
sì
cheo
peniste
cons obo
finale Paola sto un poco un
poco
non
perché i
impur F
FR sensibil
sensibilità
problema un
tempo
muscol qual professionale T
forza
forza studi muscolo frago Allora
Seo
mus muscol
frago sensib
Allora Paz perché non
forza Chi
è una
forza forza problema
E perché Perché suito muscolare differen
daito Anna paol allora
io che non diciamo
non
perché
Coner no banda
banda
B
Allora
diagono B
muscolo
Allora dupla muscolo
fo Senta Per
favore
del
delato
SIM un vantaggio eh
for dai
per
PET Pet spet giunt giun scher
giunt
centro for m
eh
qu do
Gio muscolo
For impur stabilizz No
impur
SCH che
fisis
muscolo
fiscia perché sempre sempre
sempr tamb
opisas lisas
stando
Lev 30 40° po esteriore per
violado perolado sicura paa figura
attenzione deamo
scollare stabilizzazione cha o coloc
meio do ded stabiliz mesmo eh Mita atten
eh
parima
for gamba retta Perna
perett
sicura
conch fata cheo non consigo regolare m
foris che non si
come Mori io gosto
Sim che posso impur se problema che la
fig fro impur forza che sto usando con
la F frag maess un
er adess è un erro sa e stando
ma una cos è una coscia
perché per m e non
m
musc
femmin
grande
Sì ma eh Vi per forza se io colloco a
Mao
a la fig fraga perché Eugenio ressato
adesso Meo peso sto usando perché forse
sì sì e non sto usando ben forza
poimo quello che conscious che Fat
B basso per
favore chi
c f
chegou pronta un
poco perché
muscolo
dob dob For
dob for
do for no For
for non
St Parese che
sta
Parese
musc muso
Fis
[Musica]
sempre obbligazione
sempre
bisas
dragus sempre
facciamo sempre consulta faciamo
psing in
ings
BS se
non e muscolo chinesiologica perché che
per
forza
aqui reattivo con espar significato Ess
re con
signific B
obrig
in
fessor